I thought about getting a car, but on second thought,...
...maybe I should just save it...
...until I see a decrease in the oil prices on the market.
How much does oil cost per liter in Korea?
If the price of crude oil keeps increasing,...
...it will definitely bring an unstable economy,...
...a growing gap between rich and poor,...
...and conflict among nations.
So, I'm suggesting that we should find alternative energy resources.
You know, such as wind power, solar energy, wave energy...
...or other alternate energy sources.
What would be the best one,...
...the one that sounds the most reasonable?
You are definitely right about that.
I see many ways we can save energy,...
...reduce carbon dioxide emissions and prevent climate change.
What you can do today to conserve energy is not so hard,...
...and you can make a big difference and start saving energy now.
Take public transportation, or ride a bicycle,...
...ask people to turn off their engines while waiting in their car...
...and remember to always turn off your lights...
...and electronics when leaving a room.
Right!
Especially since consumer electronics...
...play an increasingly larger role in your home's energy consumption.
These actions don't sound so hard.
The government should also encourage corporations and departments...
...to come up with affordable and practical alternative energy resources.